FROM 105 DAYS OF DONALD TRUMP.
A BUSY NEWS DAY IN TONIGHT'S
IMPORTANT OPENING MONOLOGUE.
NBC NEW REPORTING THAT MICHAEL
HOROWITZ IS COMING OUT STRONG
AGENDA JAMES COMEY, ANDREW
McCABE AND LORETTA LYNCH.
EXAMINING HOW THEY MISHANDLED
THE 2016 CRIMINAL CASE TO
HILLARY CLINTON.
WE WERE RIGHT AND YOUR MEDIA WAS
WRONG.
JAMES COMEY CLEARED HILLARY
CLINTON OF ALL CHARGES BUT NOT
BEFORE MANY MISDEEDS SURROUNDING
THE INVESTIGATION.
ONE SOURCE TOLD ABC THAT THE
DRAFT REPORT USES THE WORDS
INSUBORDINATE TO DESCRIBE
COMEY'S BEHAVIOR.
NONE OF THIS IS SURPRISING.
THE McCABE REPORT CAME OUT AND
THEN THE CRIMINAL REFERRAL.
WE KNOW ABOUT LORETTA LYNCH'S
TARMAC MEETING WITH BILL CLINTON
BEFORE SHE HELPED CLEAR HIS WIFE
OF ALL OF THESE CHARGES.
WE KNOW ABOUT McCABE'S
DEMOCRATIC TIES AND LYING.
HILLARY CLINTON DID COMMIT
FELONIES.
SHE OBSTRUCTED JUSTICE.
THAT'S INDISPUTABLE AT THIS
POINT.
ANDREW McCABE IS NOW REQUESTING
IMMUNITY FROM THE U.S. SENATE IN
EXCHANGE AGAINST HIS FORMER BOSS
JAMES COMEY.
THE FULL REPORT SHOULD HAVE BEEN
RELEASED BY NOW.
FRANKLY, IF IT'S RELEASED
BETWEEN NOW AND NEXT
WEDNESDAY -- THE SUMMIT ON
TUESDAY OF NEXT WEEK -- THAT
MEAN THEY ARE TRYING TO BURY
THIS ON A SUMMER WEEKEND SO IT
DOESN'T GET THE COVERAGE IT
NORMALLY WOULD.
IF THEY WILL RELEASE IT EARLY
NEXT WEEK THEY ARE TRYING TO
BURY IT DURING THE SINGAPORE
SUMMIT.
WHAT YOU DESERVE IS JUSTICE IN
THE FORM OF CRIMINAL REFERRALS
FOR EVERYBODY WE JUST MENTIONED.
18 LONG MONTHS AND MR
OBSTRUCTION HIMSELF OF CONGRESS,
ROB ROSENSTEIN, HE'S HAD THIS
REPORT FOR 2 WEEKS ALREADY.
I CAN ONLY IMAGINE WHAT HE IS
TRYING TO GET CHANGED OR
REDACTED.
CATHERINE HAS A NEW REPORT.
REMEMBER PETER STRZOK DEMOTED
AFTER HIS ANTI-TRUMP TEXTS WERE
AVAILABLE.
CATHERINE REPORTS HE WAS THE
LEAD INVESTIGATOR IN THE CLINTON
CASE.
HE HATED TRUMP AND WANTED THE
INSURANCE POLICY.
HE MOVED ON TO THE RUSSIA
COLLUSION CASE AND PUT ON
MUELLER'S WITCH HUNT TEAM.
THIS TRUMP HATING FBI AGENT
PLAYING A LEAD ROLE IN
EVERYTHING.
CLEARING HILLARY CLINTON AND
TAPPED TO INVESTIGATE DONALD
TRUMP.
ONE MORE REASON THE INSPECTOR
GENERAL'S REPORT SHOULD HAVE
BEEN RELEASED BY NOW.
AS THE MUELLER WITCH HUNT TURNS
ON THE SPECIAL.
THEY ARE DEMANDING THAT
WITNESSES TURN IN THEIR PHONES
SO TEAM MUELLER AND HIS PIT BULL
WEISSMAN AND RAY WHO WORKED FOR
CLINTON GET TO REVIEW ALL OF
THEIR ELECTRONIC DEVICES
COMMUNICATIONS.
EVEN TEXT ON ENCRYPTED APS.
IF THEY FOLLOW HILLARY CLINTON'S
LEAD DELETE ALL OF YOUR EMAILS
AND ACID WATCH YOUR HARD DRIVE
AND THEN BASH THEM TO PIECES AND
HAND THE PIECES OVER TO ROBERT
MUELLER AND SAY HILLARY CLINTON,
THIS IS EQUAL JUSTICE UNDER THE
LAW.
HOW WOULD THAT WORK FOR
EVERYBODY MUELLER IS DEMANDING
THEIR PHONES?
THE PERSON IN CHALLENGE OF THE
MUELLER WITCH HUNT, THE
DEPARTMENT AG, ROB ROSENSTEIN
RESPONDED TO GROWING CALLS FOR
HIS RECUSAL.
WRITING A LETTER TO SENATOR
LINDSEY GRAHAM.
HE RECOMMENDED COMEY'S FIRING.
HE SIGNED OFF ON THE FINAL FISA
WARRANT BASED ON HILLARY
CLINTON'S BOUGHT AND PAID FOR
DOSSIER THAT CHRISTOPHER STEELE
SAID MAYBE 50-50.
GIVEN THAT ROSENSTEIN IS
OVERSEEING AN INVESTIGATION
WHERE HE IS A KEY WITNESS AND
SIGNED OFF ON THE FISA, I THINK
IT'S DEEM INAPPROPRIATE A LONG
TIME AGO.
EARLIER TODAY.
FORMER NEW YORK MAYOR AND
CURRENT TRUMP ATTORNEY RUDY
GIULIANI HAD STRONG WORDS ABOUT
TRYING TO UNDO THE ELECTION OF
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
WATCH WHAT HE SAID.
>> THEY ARE A GROUP OF 13 HIGHLY
PARTISAN DEMOCRATS THAT MAKEUP
THE MUELLER TEAM AND TRYING VERY
HARD TO FRAME HIM AND GET HIM IN
TROUBLE WHEN HE HASN'T DONE
ANYTHING WRONG.
THEY MAY NOT REALIZE THEY ARE
DOING IT.
THEY CAN'T COME TO THE GRIPS TO
THE FACT OF THE WHOLE THING OF
RUSSIAN COLLUSION IS NOT HAPPEN.
THEY ARE TRYING TO INVENT
OBSTRUCTION OF JUSTICE.
THE PRESIDENT FIRED THE FBI
DIRECTOR AND HE SAID HAVE FIRED
HIM.
HE WAS A TERRIBLE FBI DIRECTOR.
>> Tucker: EVEN COMEY SAID HE
HAD THE RIGHT TO FIRE HIM.
BAD NEWS FOR THE TRUMP HATING
MAINSTREAM MEDIA.
THEIR CONSPIRACY THEORYS ABOUT
OUR FIRST LADY MELANIA TRUMP
MISSING IN ACTION CAME CRASHING
DOWN TODAY AS THE FIRST LADY
APPEARED ALONG SIDE HER HUSBAND
AT AN EVENT IN WASHINGTON, D.C.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> I WOULD LIKE TO SORT OF
MAYBE SAY AND PAY RESPECTS TO
SOME OF THE PEOPLE HERE.
I HAVE A LIST.
WE HAVE TO START WITH OUR GREAT
FIRST LADY MELANIA TRUMP.
THANK YOU.
>> [APPLAUDING].
>> SHE WENT THROUGH A ROUGH
PATCH, BUT HE IS DOING GREAT.
WE ARE PROUD OF HER.
DONE A FANTASTIC JOB AS FIRST
LADY.
THE PEOPLE OF OUR COUNTRY LOVE
YOU.
THANK YOU, HONEY.
>> Tucker: GLAD SHE IS HEALTHY
AND HER APPROVAL RATINGS ARE
HIGHER THAN THE PRESIDENT.
THE PRESIDENT TWEETED TODAY.
THAT THE FAKE NEWS MEDIA HAS
BEEN SO VICIOUS TO MY WIFE, OUR
GREAT FIRST LADY MELANIA.
THEY REPORTED EVERYTHING FROM
NEAR DEATH TO FACELIFTS TO SHE
LEFT ME TO ABUSE.
ALL FAKE.
SHE IS DOING WELL.
KIMBERLIED.
-- KIM KARDASHIAN.
SHE VISITED THE OVAL OFFICE TO
SHINE A LIGHT ON THE CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM AND A CASE
INVOLVING JOHNSON, A GREAT
GRANDMOTHER SENTENCED TO LIFE IN
PRISON AFTER FOUND GET OF
NON-VIOLENT DRUG CHARGES.
HER FIRST OFFENSE.
PRESIDENT TRUMP COMMUTED HER
SENTENCE WHO ALREADY SERVED 22
YEARS.
A FEW HOURS AGO KIM KARDASHIAN
THANKED THE PRESIDENT:
SO GRATEFUL TO EVERYONE WHO
CONTRIBUTEED TO THIS IMPORTANT
MOMENT FOR JOHNSON.
THIS GIVES HOPE TO SO MANY
OTHERS WHO DESERVE A SECOND
CHANCE.
THIS IS JUST THE BEGINNING OF
WHAT IS A LONG NEEDED
CONVERSATION IN THIS COUNTRY
ABOUT SENTENCING AND CRIMINAL
REFORM THE PRESIDENT WILL
TACKLE.
2-TIERED JUSTICE SYSTEM
STRETCHES WIDE AND FAR.
EQUAL JUSTICE UNDER THE LAW.
EQUAL APPLICATIONS OF THE LAWS.
WE WISH MISS JOHNSON ALL OF OUR
BEST.
SOMEONE WHO BENEFITTED FROM THE
2-TIER JUSTICE SYSTEM, FORMER
PRESIDENT BILL CLINTON BACK IN
THE SPOTLIGHT.
HE IS FINALLY FACE SOMETHING
BACK LASH FROM DEMOCRATS OVER
HIS LONG HISTORY OF SEXUAL ABUSE
AND MISCONDUCT.
DEMOCRATS IN THE MEDIA PROTECTED
THE CLINTONS THROUGH THE LAST
PRESIDENTIAL CAMPAIGN UNTIL
NOVEMBER 9th, 2016 THE DAY AFTER
HILLARY CLINTON LOST.
>> DO YOU FEEL MORE
RESPONSIBILITY?
>> NO, I FELT TERRIBLE THEN.
I CAME TO GRIPS WITH IT.
>> DID YOU EVER APOLOGIZE?
>> YES.
>> NOBODY BELIEVES I GOT OUT OF
THAT FREE.
I LEFT THE WHITE HOUSE $16
MILLION IN DEBT.
BUT YOU TYPICALLY HAVE IGNORED
GAPING FACTS AND I BET YOU DON'T
EVEN KNOW THEM.
APOLOGY?
>> I DO.
I NEVER TALKED TO HER.
BUT I DID SAY PUBLICY ON MORE
THAN ONE OCCASION I WAS SORRY.
I GUILT WITH IT 20 YEARS PLUS.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE STAYED WITH
ME.
I TRIED TO DO A GOOD JOB SINCE
THEN WITH MY LIFE AND WORK.
>> Sean: BILL CLINTON TRASHED
THEM FOR ASKING TOUGH QUESTIONS.
THEY FIRED BACK.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> THE FORMER BILL CLINTON
EXPRESSING SOME REGRET OVER HIS
REMARKS ABOUT MONICA LEWINSKY
HERE ON "TODAY."
MAKING FALSE ALLEGATIONS.
>> HE SAID HIS INTERVIEW WAS NOT
HIS FINEST HOUR.
MR. CLINTON MADE ANOTHER PUBLIC
APOLOGY BUT TOOK ISSUES WITH THE
QUESTIONS WE ASKED HIM.
>> THE TAPE SPEAKS FOR HIMSELF.
YOU DID NOT ASSERT THAT HE NEVER
APOLOGIZED.
>> Sean: THE REST OF THE MEDIA
IS 30 YEARS TOO LATE.
THEY GAVE BILL CLINTON A TOTAL
PASS UNTIL HIS WIFE LOST THE
ELECTION.
ON "HANNITY" WE CALLED OUT
CLINTON ALLEGED SEXUAL ASSAULT
BEFORE THE LEFT CARED ABOUT HIS
MISCONDUCT.
YOU MIGHT REMEMBER THIS.
>> YOU DESCRIBED A SEEN WHERE HE
WAS BITING ON YOUR LIP.
WHEN IT WAS OVER, HE WAS
LEAVING.
HE SAID YOU BETTER PUT SOME ICE
ON THAT.
>> AND CASUALLY PUT ON HIS
SUNGLASSES AND WALKED OUT THE
DOOR.
>> IT WAS A TERRIBLE ORDEAL.
IT WAS AN ASSAULT.
>> HE ASSAULTED YOU AGAINST YOUR
WILL?
>> YES.
>> IT'S AN ALLEGATION THAT IS
NOT MADE BY ONE WOMAN BUT
MULTIPLE.
>> MANY OF US.
HE SAID I MAY NEED TO BE GOING.
HE SAT DOWN AND PULLED DOWN HIS
PANTS.
HIS WHOLE EVERYTHING.
HE WAS EXPOSED.
I SAID I AM NOT THAT KIND OF
GIRL.
I NEED TO GET BACK TO MY DESK.
>> Sean: THAT WAS ONE OF THE
HARDEST INTERVIEWS I HAVE DONE
IN 23.5 YEARS HERE AT FOX.
WE WILL NEVER BE THE MAINSTREAM
MEDIA.
WE COVER THE STORIES THEY REFUSE
TO BECAUSE THEY ARE SO AGENDA
DRIVEN.
THESE ARE ISSUES THAT SHOULD
TRANSCEND POLITICS.
ANOTHER AMAZING PIECE OF
ECONOMIC NEWS.
PERHAPS THE BEST EVER.
FOR THE FIRST TIME SINCE THE
STATS STARTED RECORDING, THE
UNITED STATES HAS MORE JOBS
TODAY THAN JOBLESS CLAIMS.
GET THAT.
MORE JOBS AVAILABLE THAN WE HAVE
PEOPLE ON THE UNEMPLOYMENT
LINES.
WE HAVE 14 STATES TODAY WITH
RECORD LOW UNEMPLOYMENT NUMBERS
AND FOR WOMEN AND
AFRICAN-AMERICAN AND HISPANIC
AMERICANS.
IF IT WAS THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION, CHRIS MATTHEWS
WOULD HAVE A LOT OF THRILLS
RUNNING UP AND DOWN HIS LEGS